tom devlin's monster museum in boulder
city offers a living history of horror
cinema his new attraction the fright
zone is perfect for all of you ghoul
lovers jc fernandez is live with the
tale ah jc is that you yeah yes this is
my
this is my friend kirsten uh zombie
woman right here uh
tom devlin's monster museum is perfect
for halloween
and here's the man himself tom devlin
tom how would you describe your museum
and set up to someone
so our place is a place one of a kind
that you can come and see screen used
props like these puppets from the puppet
master series
to uh one of a kind works of art like
the killer clowns from there
yeah i saw this movie it's a scary movie
all these movies are scary uh this is
the actual screen users
yourself these are just custom re-fabbed
versions of the clowns and uh the
original heads were made for
a mass company but that uh these guys
right here are one of a kind let's walk
around the corner because you have so
much
uh to see here inside your museum and
this is a the back room here i like i
like a lot because these are kind of the
characters that we're familiar with
right
we have here halloween yeah halloween
michael myers we have the leprechaun
ash from the evil dead one of my
personal favorites leatherface right
behind you here
and what's so great about this place it
is so instagram worthy you can walk
through here you can take pictures
i want to cuz we got jason back here
this is so cool
you come down here you take a picture of
jason it's so
so realistic and it's you post it on
instagram it's a perfect thing
to post with your friends
and there's scares that happen inside
the monster monster museum as well is
this guy always back here or is he just
kind of here hanging out for me he is
not always back here but
in october after 7 p.m the lights go out
and we
replace some of the displays with live
monsters so the monsters come alive at
our uh nightmare at the monster museum
and my heart is now pounding because of
that guy that's standing back there to
scare me
and what's great too is we have our mask
on you have safety protocols in place as
well
and come back here because we do have
back here this is kind of the west
craven room every room has a theme
yeah yeah so we have freddy of course
pluto from the hills have eyes and
scream
this is all wes craven's work now come
back here this is this museum is
non-stop
every time you come around a corner
there's something new come back this way
lancy come around here
and what room is this back here with
this is our zombie stephen king room so
we represent all the george romero
zombies we bridge the gap with creep
show which stephen king and
george romero teamed on and then of
course we have tar man behind you from
return of the living dead the greatest
zombie film of all time now come out
through here this is the uh
enter we're going to kind of leave the
uh monster museum itself and come into
the lobby area
when you come inside here in the lobby
you have all kinds of halloween stuff
for sale as well yeah and then coming up
we're going to head to the fright zone
the fright zone that's our uh
our gallery of fear which is next door
and it is 100
scary halloween walk through i love it
tom devlin's monster museum i'm sorry
you guys my heart is racing from that
scare that he had planted there for me
but coming up we're gonna go check out
the fright zone and i'm sure i'm going
to be scared at some point again we'll
send it back to you guys in the studio
stay strong jc stay strong well